ariana grande fan is first victim  confirmed dead in Manchester attack my  relationship with my fans is like I  wouldn't trade it for anything  et has learned eighteen-year-old  Georgina Calendar died Monday night  after a bomb went off following Ariana's  performance killing at least 22 people  the night before the singer's concert  Georgina tweeted ariana so excited to  see you tomorrow just two years prior  Georgina got to meet the popstar  backstage at the Manchester Arena in  2015  outside of being a huge fan of Ariana  and her music Georgina was a student in  her second year and run Shaw college  studying health and social care  a spokesperson for run Shaw shared in a  statement to ET quote our deepest  sympathies thoughts and prayers go out  to all of Georgina's family